warum ist dieses stück leinen glaube ich
habe gerade überlegt ob ich den akzent
nach mache aber das gefühl das ist ganz
bisschen ost ist darüber kommen könnte
ob sie macht ja auf ihn aber sie kommt
aus kolumbien ich könnte den bräunlichen
akzenten machen aber dann geht das
wieder alles in eine komische richtung
wollen wären nicht also bevor das wieder
niemandem auffällt alle kleid gloria
also in der folge hat sie so ein
blumenkleid an und das einzige was ich
mit blumenmuster habe das hier und ich
sage mal her und make up ist auch von
ihr inspiriert könnte ich öfter so
tragen aber in dem format geht es
natürlich nicht um äußerlichkeiten
sondern um sondern sondern um gut
sondern um futter ist der report den
einem ohne dieser stelle bedanke ich
mich für den vorschlag unter meinem
letzten geschmeckt video dass ich die
soße von gloria mal ausprobieren soll
wohl ich model verliebt model fern
obwohl ich modern familiy komplett rich
geschaut habe konnte ich mich
tatsächlich nicht an diese stelle
erinnern dass sie mal erwähnt was
überhaupt in dieser spezial soße drin
ist natürlich ist diese soße später ja
auch in den folgen auch noch ein thema
und man weiß dass es anscheinend eine
leckere soße aber sie sagt tatsächlich
alle zutaten auf sobald kämen sie darauf
anspricht dass die zutaten ja irgendwo
in ihrem kopf versteckt sind und ich
finde wie sie auf diese zutaten kommt
ist die perfekte beschreibung für diesen
modern family humor irgendwie so richtig
schwarz und einfach mega lustig
irgendwie ich finde das einfach ich
liebe modern family sie hat draußen
etwas was wir so ein kuss klingt und da
sie aus kolumbien kommt erinnert wie sie
dass ihre tante koriander dabei richtig
laut geschnitten hat damit sie die
schüsse übertönt und dann erinnerte sie
sich auch an alle anderen zutaten und
für die soße brauchen wir
kapern halle b mio und eine prise
schwarzem pfeffer lassen die zutaten die
sie uns an der stelle verrät da es aber
eine tomatensoße whatever wird brauchen
wir natürlich geschälte ganze tomaten
ein bisschen tomatenmark und mir hat
jemand auf twitter verraten dass in
einer anderen folge eine ganz spezielle
paprika suchen die sie für diese soße
brauch und da dachte ich da ist ja eh
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen scharf
sein soll habe ich scharfe paprika
passte genau ist jetzt aus korea aber
ansich brauchen wir diesen paprika
geschmack und diese spezielle paprika
wären wir eh nicht finden
und am ende soll es ja auch schmecken
und so kleinkariert brauchen wir auch
nicht sein lasst uns mal loslegen und
schauen wie glas kolumbianische familien
so schmeckt zuerst machen wir den
koriander auf und wir merken wie gras
koriander re ich sehe absolut keine
mengenangaben in der folge oder zutaten
man sieht einfach nur am ende wie kämen
sie probiert und sie liebt und deswegen
machen wir es aus dem bauch heraus
natürlich zuerst waschen
[Musik]
und jetzt so laut schneiden dass wir die
schüsse von draußen übertönen können
also manchmal wenn timo zur kirche
wirklich schüsse und 123 funktioniert
besser als gedacht
fertig geschnitten und wenn eure ganze
küche nach koriander riecht dann geht es
weiter mit kapern und rapace ich würde
sagen so ein löffel kleckern statt
klotzen ist meine diese und noch mal die
schüssel übertönen mit irqa von
schnipseln geschnitten
hall ab - und ein anderes kann man
frisch kaufen oder man kauft sie so wie
ich aus dem glas frische champignons
sind sehr schwer zu finden mein
supermarkt sie nur manchmal und ja was
soll ich dazu sagen sind doch einfach
aus dem glas auch richtig geil diese
soße solms im arsch haben wegen machen
wir so viel ist es wenig ich kann meinen
einer fahrerlaubnis ist ja ich frage
euch sicher knie ich gerade für meine
küchenzeile ja technisch nicht so
einfach dass man jetzt brauchen wir
unseren ländlich hard-fi wohne ja ki
moon hat dazu gelernt ich glaube ich
muss euch das nicht erklären ihr
entsaften eine zitrone
das riecht sehr zwei leitet und da wird
alle zutaten gehackten gepresst haben
können wir uns an die tomatensoße
ranmachen bzw jetzt alle zutaten
kombinieren wir brauchen unseren top und
in diesen topf kommen die geschälten
tomaten riechen die gut und nun wollen
die guten tomatensaft nicht verlieren
deswegen machen wir natürlich wasser
rein studiums einmal durch
das erhitzen wir kam ich kann mich nicht
an das rezept alina sie ist über 30
jahre her weil ich keine zeit damit die
soße booms hat kommt noch ein bisschen
tomaten marke rein so viel und wir
probieren unsere scharfe paprika bastel
[Musik]
dir echt gut
wow
oh mein gott noch nie besonders leckeres
probiert dafür mache ich einen teelöffel
rain man mit 2 und weil wir so frech
sind machen es einfach alle anderen
zutaten auch rein natürlich demonews was
darf nicht fehlen
weil es eigentlich unmöglich ist dass da
kein salz tones meinung ist ich kann es
mir nicht vorstellen
die soße lassen jetzt noch köcheln und
wir sehen uns gleich wieder späte glaube
ich hätte lieber frische tomaten nehmen
müssen die einmal kochen dann schälen
dann kochen dann hätte man irgendwie
eine gröbere soße gehabt wo wir draußen
die kinder das funktioniere nicht immer
so wie man sich es vorstellt vor allem
sieht man halt auch nicht wie sie es
zubereitet und sie sagt hält nichts von
tomaten oder knoblauch oder zwiebeln sie
hat er nur diese paar zutaten auf gesagt
haben legen wir unser sieht und unsere
schüssel darunter und dann bald wieder
sitzt da rein
fehler passieren
auch den besten köchen die genau
aussieht ein bisschen zeit zu machen
große baustelle sagt ja immer wieder
wunder geschehen überall
die es fertig ist fertig die jetzt
fertig ich brauche nur brauchen ein
macht ja ich habe keine macht klar das
macht auch hat sie doch auch nicht
schlecht aus jetzt kommen wir sind nicht
unsere idee atouba glas reihen
das sieht aus wie eine tomatensoße aber
es sieht aus wie sie mit dip soße und
nicht wieso ihr wisst was ich meine
doch das ist die soße die geheimen
familienrezept sauce von glorious
familie schwierig gut da sie mit schon
kam die soße nicht mit nazis probieren
lassen sondern mit so einem stück brot
nehme ich jetzt einfach getesteten toast
und dann probieren wir den test dafür
nehmen wir la bridges weißbrot und
packende sind in österreich nicht
nachmachen kindermann fest nicht in den
toaster rein ohne ihn nicht anzusehen
man könnte einen elektronischen schock
reden
gleich gehts ans probieren ich habe
keine geduld mehr
ich weiß weissbrodt ist nicht so gesund
das wisst ihr vielleicht nicht aber wenn
ihr tost es holt euch bitte den
vollkorntoast das gefühl da freut sich
adam lambert bewerber für das tut mir
noch was gut ist aber das ist auch
einfach geil okay ich bin so gespannt
und nun stelle man wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
glorias geheimen familienrezept soße aus
modern family also mit elke probst
also ich hab die tomaten noch mit so
einem stampfer einfach klein gestampft
und ich probiere damit das so stickig
bleibt wo alois dies lux very very good
okay okay wenn man kein koriander mag
wird man die auch nicht mögen die
schmeckt sehr nach koriander aber sehr
lecker ein bisschen weniger kapern hits
auch getan sie hat ordentlich bums aber
so lecker wie ist noch so lecker scharf
und nicht so irgendwie schaut sondern
suchen scharf vor allem ist da nicht
mehr knoblauch oder zwiebeln darin wie
schmeckt sie ich versuche den geschmack
zu beschreiben wann kriegt eine richtig
gute stelle von den harmlos sie macht so
kann diese scharfe paprika passte die
schmeckt man auch und dann gehen diese
tomaten so ein fashion week ein bisschen
zu viel körper ahlmann schmeckst du
zuviel körpern haben aber auch ganz
schön mit den covern übertrieben muss
ich muss ich an dieser stelle sagen wie
moore könntest du nur testweise sie mal
probieren
der safe toys linktipp das anders sie
rein kosten sie ist ein bisschen warm
und was habe ich finde hier vorgeführt
eine mehr tobias machen können da hat
alles drin was du mich mag korea japan
du hast oder schaffen sie hassen sie
schmeckt so lecker essen gerne koriander
ich hasse koriander wie richtig wir
haben
sorry aber könnten sie forschen
gut schmecken würde die hatten mit
koriander markt auf jeden fall vor
gericht keine scherben richtig gut so
stimmt das noch keiner penis in die
masse auch hier wenig gemacht haben hier
überhaupt geschwächt chaos und die von
geräten
die drei sachen die ich übertrieben
hardware hätte ja sein können dass die
sich so - - - machtlos also man kann
festhalten wenn ihr kein freund von
pantaenius oder koriander seit wird
diese soße euch nicht schmecken wenn ihr
allerdings diese drei sachen mögt ich
glaube werdet ihr es mögen wie immer
hoffe ich euch hat die folge gefallen
und wenn ja dann zeigt sind unbedingt
den daumen nach oben damit können die
mich mega gut unterstützen und schlagt
mir doch gerne ein neues rezept vor also
ich habe das letzte rezept ja auch aus
einem kommentar genommen vielleicht habt
ihr eine gute idee
es wäre nett wenn ihr dazu schreiben
könnte wo es wirklich auftaucht wenn es
nicht zu viel verlangt ist vielleicht
auch die minuten angabe oder so damit
ich mir dann wirklich anschauen kann was
ihr meint und damit ich es auch leichter
finden kann
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
ich hoffe euch geht es gut space age und
bis bald
[Musik]
gloria